首先强调一下，为什么选了这个电影有几方面的原因，第一方面的原因是这个电影是非常典型的。
电影型的故事就是集中时间内紧急情况发生的事情。我们说这种情况下一般来说是非常适合做电影的，为啥呢？因为它先天具有紧迫感，它的钩子很强，不太会让你觉得无聊。就这种片子啊很难觉得无聊。因为它的时当时间跨度非常短啊。
这是第一个原因。第二个原因呢，这个电影是由真实事件改编的。关于真实事件改编电影，我在课上也讲过，对吧？你可以通过新闻，通过一些纪录片，通过一些历史书去导找到一些真真人真事儿，然后把它改编成电影。那么改编的时候的尺度问题，对吧？改编的程度问题。
我们这节课也可以探讨，这是我们学习的第二个方面啊，我选这个片子的第三个原因就是我们可以欣赏一下呃丹泽尔华盛顿的演技啊，大家会盘点一些非常厉害的演技。
就好莱，比如说好莱坞十大演技什么男神之类的啊，丹泽尔华盛顿肯定在肯定在里面啊。我觉得它既有技巧，也有气势和气质啊。所以说今天这个片子啊非常典型的电影故事，又是以真实事件为基础的一个改编，所以非常值得我们去学习。
今天做一个不一样的训练，我们先简单拉一下这个片子的呃信息节拍。在这里我强调一下这个电影的信息节拍，大同学们咱们之间有出入，没有关系，是因为它的视角很多，所以它切的很碎。
视角为什么很多？你用脑子想一想就知道了，因为集中时间发生的事儿，对吧？它的长度是有限的，只能增加宽度，增加宽度的一个方法就是增加视角。所以说他每一次切换视角它就换场了。也也就是说同一个信息节班被切成了死段。
因为要跟其他五六个视角平行排布。你如果不切换视角，你那两手诗素材都凑不出来，对不对？
我们看一下这部电影怎么做，我粗粗的尝试给大家搞了一个信息节拍啊，呃，不准，但是无所谓啊，因为它这个片子全是事情太多，来看一下，先看第一幕，第一分钟先交代环境啊，先交代时空环境，这是一个铁轨的故事，火车的故事。由于这部片子啊镜头运用的。
镜头运用非常丰富，学导演的同学啊，我先强调一下，将来想当导演或者学导演的同学可以好好看一下这部电影。这部电影的镜头一云用是非常到位的啊，那种压迫感，那种速度感，这种特殊题材啊，他有时候需需要你拍出这种压迫感和速度感。你去呃学习一下这部电影的镜头，包括。
由于他还要营造几个感觉啊，压迫感速度感，他还要营造真实感。
真实感为什么呢？真实事件改编呀，而且里面还有很多新闻视角，有很多手持的镜头。第一趴就是第一分钟先交代这个火车啊，先交代这个火车，火车、铁轨啊，火车铁轨是美国的一个重要文化。这个我们待会儿再探讨，然后顺便演出片头，非常干净啊。嗯我们说这个呃计实类的片子，还有一个特点啊。
同学们自己去体会一下啊，就是BGM一般用的比较少啊，很难停下来嘎嘎开始唱歌，但是也不会完全不用，有一些轻微的小点缀啊，计时类的片子很难停下来放一段抒情的音乐。所以说呃交代了火车这个环境就迅速进片头了。
第二趴也就是第二分钟啊，我们小帅登场。
嗯，同学们，我们就叫他小帅吧，角色名没有那么重要，咱们就管这个年轻一点的男主叫小小帅啊，年老一点的，我们叫他老司机来第二他小帅登场啊，然后交代了一下他的居住环境，他正在睡沙发啊，呃说明他有一个呃困境就是分居的困境。他的家庭出现问题了啊。
先交代了一下他的他的环境，然后再交代了一下他的困境。我们同学们要明白啊，要明白这场戏非常干净啊非常干净。
然后第三趴。
第三趴来到第3分钟，两个男主碰头。
两个男主碰头啊，我们暂且叫他们两个男主啊，也就是老司机和小帅碰头，然后环境很不友好，为什么不友好呢？上来就有火花。我们说这两个人的相识，上来就有火花，为什么？
因为小帅是个关系户，你可以理解在美国铁路系统可能也挺肥的。
呃，第第四拍他切了很多段，实际上第4分钟、第6分钟、第8分钟都在埋一个伏笔，就是这些工作人员疏忽大意。
要搞出事情了，暗示要出问题。他用镜头语言用这种窥有点窥探的这种视角啊。同学们镜头是可以说话的，他用一些窥探视角让你感受到要出事儿了啊。
来第五拍。
第5分钟，小朋友们正在组织参观铁路系统，这个很重要啊，因为这是一个单独的视角，我们待会儿要讲，所以说我们单拎出来，虽然就是一个镜头，第五拍就是一帮小朋友要来参观铁路系统，好吧，来第六拍第回到我们双男主这边第7分钟。
然后按，然后开始交代两个人的什么。刚才的相识，我们说是不打不相识，相识完了开始做什么不相识，相识完了做互补。
所以第六拍两个人是吧，一个经验非常丰富，28年了，一个才4个月，对吧？然后两个人有各种要各种的差异啊，各种的矛盾，两个人是互补的，两个人不一样，知道吧？两个人都是相反的一些人设，对吧？一黑一白一老一少，一个要退休，一个新入职。
但是呢也交代了两个人共同点，就两个人各自有各自的困境吧啊，都有孩子。第七拍第9分钟你可以延你可以理解它是第四拍的延续，你把它归在第四拍也可以。就是那边工作人员失误叠加，有一列火车失控走了，也就是我们这个故事的主要的那个危机啊，期待他们的这个呃基督教文化里面代表死亡啊，代表死神。
所以说777我们可以理解为死神号，因为原版因为真实事件那个火车是888挺吉利的是吧？888。
然后呢，拍成电影改成了777啊，我们就叫他死神。二火车呢失控溜走了。来到第八拍啊，继续强化两个男主的困境。第11分钟啊，第八拍第11分钟继续强化男主的困境。他女儿过生日啊，他女儿过生日呃，他打电话给他女儿，他女儿生他的气。
然后呢呃这里就展现咒语啊，男主说你我你放心，我晚上早点回去给你过生日啊。咒语知道吧？这种话是一定要说的，为什么？
同学们，为什么？
为什么在这里要刻意营造这些东西啊？
因为真实事件改编的电影，最吃亏的地地方就是结局我们是差不多知道的，对吧？我们也知道待会要出事的，所以在这里把氛围拉满，肯定没毛病啊，把氛围都拉满啊。
然后呢，女儿还挂她电话，对吧？不跟他说话，留下遗憾，对吧？如果死了，那我不完了吧。然后这两个人呢磕磕绊绊各怀心事，继续吵架，对吧？嗯，现实背景就是新旧交替嘛。呃老的被开除，女的呃老的已经被被替掉了，嗯，新的顶上来啊，新旧交替的这么一个困境，两个人继续磕磕绊绊。
来第九拍回到第14分钟，这一拍非常的重要，这一拍非常的重要。
调度处的这个这个女孩叫什么？叫connyhooper是吧？我们叫她小美，我们调度处的小美采取第一次措施对记第一次措施，想要追回失控的这个火车，同时呢要求参观的那个火车改道。
参观的那个火车上是谁呀？小朋友对不对啊？是小朋友要求参观的火车装着小朋油的那个火车啊，改道，他要采取补救措施。
然后回到我们的车车上第十拍。当然了，这个第十拍你写单是不是要单独写成一拍无所谓啊。因为人家切开了，咱就切开说回到这个车上，两个人开始交流理解，找到一些共同点啊，找到一些共同点。也就是说这两个大男人磕磕绊绊的在磕磕绊绊的在执行第一次任务。
好吧，点缀一下，实际上这个镜头没什么用啊，我们待会儿再说他为什么这么搞回到第十一拍。
第19分钟。
第一次补救措施失败。
危机升级。
开始第二次补救措施。
我们待会儿数一下，针对这个事情一共采取了几几几种计划。我们待会儿数一下，针对这个事情一共采取了几种计划。同学们在这个故事里面。
拯救777。
死神号是唯一的任务。
所以每一步计划你记下来，你就知道为什么一个故事需要这么去构建，这么需需要它紧凑，对吧？其实蛮无聊的一个故事，如何让它紧凑啊，开始采取第二个计划啊来。
1二拍22分钟，死神号和小朋友们的参观火车擦肩而过，而且非常的危险。同学们。
一个戏里面如果出现小朋友，或者是你刻意安排的小朋友，一定要记住借小朋友的嘴说出咒语。
我再说一遍。
如果。
你的戏里面有小朋友，或者是你刻意安排了小朋友，一定要记住，用小朋友的嘴说出咒语。我们说童言无忌才是最吓人的。
让小朋友说出对火车安全的注意事项或者担忧。
浪。
借小朋友的嘴巴说出咒语，童言无忌是最吓人的啊。
来来到第13拍，23分钟。
我们小帅啊小帅，人家这个美国有个东西叫禁止令，就发现你这个人不安全，就禁止你靠近谁谁谁，你靠近了，人家可以报警抓你是吧？禁止令啊，禁止令。
然后呢，他这个禁止令的困境继续困扰他。实际这个困境我们前面已经给过了，但是在这里再给一次啊再给一次。因为这里刷男主如果这里不强调困境，整个第一第一幕和第二幕都没他俩什么事儿啊，都没他俩什么事儿所以说在这里再一次给到他的困境问题。也就是他这个孩子探望他孩子的这个问题啊。
你不用管你那边翻成什么，实际就是一个禁止令。你可以理解，比如说有一个人一直骚扰你，你可以向法庭申请禁止令。然后这个人比如说你前男友对吧，这个人就不允许靠近你500米以内来来到第14趴，也就是第25分钟。小美制定的第二次拯救计划再次失败。
再次失败。
记住啊，再次失败。
然后来到第十五趴。
也就是第26分钟。
我们这个小帅出错了啊，小帅搞出一件事情，记得很清楚啊。小帅在这里有原罪，他多接了5节车厢，小帅在这里有个原罪啊，同学们这里呼应为什么最后是小帅力挽狂澜？
这里呼应一下为什么是小帅力挽狂澜。
因为小帅在这里出错了啊，他多接了5节车厢，导致两个人吵架。
同时，两个人第一次接到关于777这个事件的命令，什么命令啊？
让他们避让给我记一下，这个事情发生在第26分钟，让他们避让。
30。
来。
第十六排。
29分钟，各种新闻视角，各种报道啊开始增加气氛。整个事情正式开始了，捅出去了，出事儿了。好吧，然后第1七拍来到30分钟，在调度处发大家交通过交流信息知道了这个车上运的是有毒的易燃物啊，具有有毒的化学物质，也有易燃物。
它就是一个正在飞速运行的炸弹啊，非常危险。所以。
在这里，小美提出了第三个计划。
也就是让火车趁火车还在郊区，让火车脱轨自行爆炸。小美执行的制定的第三个计划。
被驳回来到第十八拍啊第十八拍来到第32分钟。
然后在火车铁轨附近发生了意外的车祸啊，导致死神号的威胁加大。在这里呢这部片子竟然用了一点BGM我们说啊这种计时类的片子不太用BGM。我们看一下啊，第32分钟，这里用了一点。我们为了他为了营造这个火车的危险BG啊，用了点BGM。
非常克制的用了一点B剑啊，我们可以看一下啊，重点就是要学习一下啊，这个这个呃正常来说这种气温记事片啊很多都不用啊，很多都不用。但是呢轻微的用一下呃来点来点这个气氛啊，来 you have to get off.
1九拍34分钟，我们这个主角窗南主的这个火车并不能按计划进入测线。
是因为我们小帅的原罪啊，我们小帅多接了几节车厢，他们进不去，好吧，来到第20拍36分钟。
开始交代这件事情引发的反应，从社会的角度，从高层的角度，每个人关心的东西不一样，对吧？高层关心股票会不会跌，群众关心这个东西是不是安全。
大家的视角不一样。
2一拍。
来到第37分钟，在调度处理第四个计划开始实施。当然了，第四个计划并不是我们那个小小美的计划啊，第四个计划直升机空降这个计划是高层的啊，用一个阻力车去阻挡这个死神号，然后用直升机空降一个人上去。
22拍也就是第39分钟回到我们1206号列车，就是我们这个主角团。我们回去我们下面就叫他1206啊。那事实证明我们这个老司机啊，我们这个这个这个老司机是对的，他他们这个车进不了侧线。但是呢他们暂时也无处躲藏啊，他们只能在主赛道上无处测躲藏。
然后来到第23拍，也就第41分钟。记住啊，第四个计划。
失败了。
空降计划失败啊，有人牺牲了在这里死人了啊。第41班第二呃第41分钟来到第24排，第45分钟。
康尼和我们的1206取得了直接联系。小美啊和我们1206号取得了直接联系。然后这个二人组即将正面遇到死神号。
然后第25拍也就是第47分钟啊，两个人准备英勇了，对吧？因为正面遇到死神号了，所以呢两呃那个呃这个老司机就打电话给女儿有点告别的意思。但是呢最后时刻呢，他们俩和死神号擦肩而过并没有死。
故事终点，这里是故事终点啊，就他俩没事儿了，他俩安全了，他俩躲过去了，这是故事终点。
接着往下第26拍。
第49分钟，老司机发现问题，他认为那个调度员是错的，调度员即将执行的计划是错的是没有用的。他们两个人决定执行自己的计划去追赶40号。
他们俩好不容易躲过一劫，现在他们俩要去追死神号，他们俩想想想拯救第27拍来到第50分钟。
我们这个小美和1206进行沟通，得知了1206这个计划，他需要请示上级。第28盘。
我们这个小美和上级沟通之后，被骂了一段啊，被禁止。然后嘞，包括这个高层威胁要开除他们。但是我们这个老司机并不害怕，为什么呢？因为老司机已经被已经被开除了，这个戏剧化很强啊呃，这种这种戏剧戏这个。
我们说这个就是拉满啊，这就是改编。
现实题材啊改编成影视，一定要把这些冲突都拉满啊，他已经被开除了，所以他无所谓，他们决定去拯救这个列车。然后我们这个小美是支持支持他们的啊。
第29拍来到第55分钟，我们这个1206和小美呢保持着沟通，互通数据，对吧？然后这个小小小小美是是支持他们的。然后这两个人呢，我们这个双人组呢也开始啊吐露心声，开始聊起各自的困境然后第30拍来到第58分钟，然后社会的视角啊，第三方视角，包括新闻视角啊。
都在关心这个事儿，但是这一拍最重要的是什么呢？又有一个新的计划，这第几个计划了？
第几个计划了？
如果加上直升机空降。
啊，第五个了啊，不算我们主角团的计划啊，这是第五个计划了。警察准备用枪击安全阀门是吧？用枪打中飞驰的列车上的一个小小东西失败啊又失败。我们说这是第五个计划啊。
来到第3一拍。
60分钟，然后两个人的事情被新闻报道引发关注啊，引发关注。
我们说那么这个这个这个。
引发关注呃，这一拍非常重要，是因为后面他们的孩子要通过这个新闻来跟他们进行隔空的一个一个一个关联啊。来第32拍第六个计划，高层的那个在车上嗯，那个在轨道上安装那个高层安安装的那个计划啊，果然失败了。
第六个计划果然失败了啊，这时候呢就导致一个情况，1206成为了整件事唯一的希望。
第33拍来到63分钟。
两个人继续互相治愈啊，聊家庭，聊亲人。
然后刚才说引起了新闻的注意，那么他们的家人啊，小帅的妻子，包括我们这个。
我们这个老司机的两个女儿，我们说老司机的两个女儿设置的非常好，在在huotters上班，然后呢都关注到这件事情了，社会层面都很紧张啊，社会层面都很紧张。来到第34排，也就是65分钟。
越来越多的人加入到这件事情当中，也提出了新的建议啊，提出了新的建议。还有小帅哥也提出了自己的新的建议。在这里，小帅也提出了自己的新想法，新冒险。也就是说。
现在1206成为了唯一的希望，前面6个6个的措施都失败了之后，6个拯救方案全部失败以后，现在只剩下我们1206这唯一一个唯一一个。
这个这个。
解决方案。但是在这个解决方案里也不断出现新情况啊。在这里小帅也提出一个新的冒新的想法，新的冒险啊。
然后小帅要要上这上上场了。第35拍第68分钟把两个车连在一块。这件事情呢出现问题啊，小帅严重受伤，但是冒险完成了任务啊，小帅严重受伤，冒险完成了任务，这排还挺长的。
第36拍来到第71分钟。
他们两个人的第一步计划完成啊，开始拖拽。
逐渐逼近我们说那叫什么死亡弯道啊，鼻逐渐逼近死亡弯道，上了一个时间锁，说这个车过不了那个弯道啊。
第37拍来到74分钟。第二步计划失败。
拽不过他拽不过死神号啊，拽不过死神号。也就是说他们俩人把好不容易把车连在一起了之后，呃，想拽拖拽这个死神号不行，拽不过拽不过之后呢，又想到一个新办法啊，又想到一个新办法，也就是死神号上面的每个每节车厢的手动制动，是可以打开，这样的话可以帮助减速，这次呢是老司机老司机过去。
老司机过去。
然后来到第38拍，也就是75分钟，老司机来到死神号，手动制动每一节车厢啊，火车逼近死亡弯道的同时，车速确实逐渐下降了。
然后第39牌来到第77分钟又出现新问题了。
车头的也就是1206号的刹车报废了，车速又开始提升，主力刹车报废了，车速又开始提升，即将到达啊即将到达死亡弯角。
然后第40拍来到79分钟，这两个人凭借老司机的经验隔空配合，突法制动啊，惊险的通过了弯道，逃过一劫啊，逃过了一劫。
41拍来到81分钟，他们有最新的计划是赶到车头啊，赶到车头。但是呢我们老司机呢往车头赶的时候跳不过去了啊，跳不过去了，有一节跳不过去，遇到问题。第42拍83分钟又有一个新的计划，也就是那个最早的那个有一个修理工那个扎小辫的那个啊那个。
我们说他是个焊接工，我们不管啊，我们叫他小辫儿吧。小辫儿开着皮卡赶到啊，开着皮卡赶到。然后在这里呢，小帅跳进了车里赶到车头啊。
然后第43拍85分钟，小帅跳进了死神号啊，小帅跳进了死神号，两个人终于拯救了死神号。第44拍87分钟，英雄归来，然后两个人实现各种成长，弥补了之前所有的缺陷。也就是说他们的家人全都来来到了他们的身边，也不生他们的气了。
也为他们而骄傲啊，弥补了两个人收获了最重要的东西。也就是说，两个人通过拯救这个呃列车做的这件事情，弥补了各自所有的缺陷。
然后最后又来一盘45拍啊，在这个铁路现场嗯，大家欢庆胜利。然后那个这个英雄组和这个康尼啊，英雄二人组。我们说这个老司机和小帅跟我们的小美终于见面了啊，这三个人终于见面了基本上就是这么个剧情流程啊，基本上就这么个剧情流程。
我们来先学几个知识点啊，我们来先学一下双男主的互。
同学们，你们告诉我这个电影里面这个双相反的双男主的设定，这个互补人家都做了哪些，有哪些是比较厉害的，一黑一白一老一少就算了啊，一黑一白一老又少，这种很肤浅表很表面的咱们就不说了。
我们说比较好的啊。
第一。
一个非常爱他的妻子，但是妻子已经死去了。
对吧。
另外一个呢。
涉嫌家暴，当然了，他没有真的打，因为一旦打女人这个这个主角就很难救回来了啊。但是他确实情绪不稳定，把他老婆吓走了，差点打老婆。我们说这个相反做的非常好啊，一个走后门进入了体制内铁道铁道系统。
另外一个，因为公司改革被裁员了。
没有背景被裁员了。
是吧。
当然了，一老一新，一个毛躁，一个稳健，这都是相反。但是这几个互补我们说。
是比较。
优美的，为什么呢？因为我们。
但会要弥补这些。
我们说一黑一白一老一少，我们最后这两件事情不成长呀。结束的时候，他他们俩还是一黑一白一老一少呀，对吧？
但是家人的爱，他们后面是可以成长的。
懂吗？
包括那个老老司机的工作最后也拯救了吗？老司机的被辞退了这件事情，最后不也拯救了吗？这些是留有成长空间的这种互补。这就是我说的啊，这种互补比较重要，比表面的一黑一白一胖一瘦，一老一少一高一矮要重要的多。
好不好啊？这个点啊大家自己去体会一下关于这两个角色的互补，大家去体会一下，互补之外，一定要有共通之处。这两个人的责任心，这两个人的勇敢是共通的。
明白吗？即便是我们说绿皮书，绿皮书这家角两个角色也有共同之处呀，对不对？
同学们，基于这一点。
去体会一下啊体会一下。
我们再来聊一个问题。
这个故事的主角是谁？
这个故事啊传统意义上来说，当然是双男主，对吧？当然是这两个男孩子，再加上我们的小美对吧？三个主角。
但是。
它里面有个问题啊。
双男主在整个故事终点以前严重缺乏主动力。
而一次一次想拯救火车的是谁呢？
所以说如果只看我们只看剧本，只看故事。
在整个故事的前半段，小美的主动性更强。
也就是说，单看故事的前半段，你可以理解小美更小。
然后故事的后半段呢，其实小美也没闲着。
他也一直在重度参与整个拯救事件，但是呢戏份确实交给了两个男主。
我们这只是探讨技术层面啊，同学们不用不用去，大家不用去上纲上线。
我知道这部片子外界的主角，那当然是。
那两个男主对吧？人家都得最佳男主奖。
但是在故事的中前段。
拥为有主动性的是小美。
那么在这种情况下。
我们怎么。
来理。
整个故事的。
结构呢？
假设。
以小美的视角来理。
那就是小美为了拯救列车所做出的N多次尝试是吧？六七次尝试五六次的尝试。
然后以此为线索。
如果以双男主的视角。
来看的话。
那么。
你可以理解，假设我们以双男主，我们不管草美，就双男主是主角，爱谁谁谁来天花来老子来了也不好使，我们就认为主角是。
这个双男主。
那么双男主在故事终点以前。
他们的目标是什么呢？
他们的目标是避开死神号。
我再说一遍，你自己去体会一下。
双男主在故事终点之前的任务是避开死神号。
你们回想一下，多装了几节车厢，进不了侧线，对吧？要避开，但是没时间了啊，最后时刻避开，然后后后屁股还让人撞烂了。
那么后半段呢？
前半段终于终避开了死神套，获得了一个虚假的胜利。后半段呢又去追赶死神号，并且拯救死神号。
也就是说，我们按照传统思维这个故事的主角是。
说男主的话是老司机和小小帅的话，那他们在故事终点之前是要避开死神号，避开危险。那故事后半段呢要去追赶死神号，并且拯救死伤。
那我们来看一下，由于他目前整个故事中前段双男主存在感偏低，所以花了大量的篇幅。
做了几个补救方案啊。
我们来看一下。
由于故事在中前部，我们的双男主没有什么目标，他做了哪些补救措施？首先，双男主的感情做的比较扎实。
两个人呢磕磕绊绊聊天啊做的比较多。另外呢切了很多视角啊，切了很多视角。我们说这故事有多少视角？
1206的一个视角，调度室一个视角，工作人员，一个视角，两个人各自的家人，一个视角，参观的小朋友一个视角，新闻视角是吧？
各种视角各种视角来来来用多人物啊多人物来交代。
我们再来看一个东西啊，再来一个看一个东西。
有没有交代过半点前十啊，同学们。
这么多的人物。
然后我们俩我们两个双男主各自有各自的困境，在这个电影当中用过一次闪回吗？
仅仅用了几通电话。
仅仅用了几通电话，同学们啊。
而且好的人物设定同学们，我们来看一场戏啊，我们说当然了，你如果闪回整个戏的节奏就掉了。
但是我们需要交代，我们确实需要交代他们经历过什么，确实需要交代一些东西，我们是有办法的，可以完全可以在当前交代的呀。
我给你们看一场戏啊，来我们看18分钟一场戏。
我认。
No families from standing.
来。
行。
So, it's a long story got a long day.
。
他会有你们。
story once got two beautiful daughters though 1819, they both waitres ain't trying to work to Waake through college we're at Hooters.
ot all right, that's right,ot off your face, you blush.
就这位。
来。
这场戏。
我们说这场细交代的。
完全不用闪回，完全不用交代他们以前经历过什么，一个担心的父亲带着两个马上要上大学的女儿。同学们有没有人去猫头鹰餐厅吃过饭？上海有一家，我给你们讲一下啊，回头你们可以自己去网上搜一下猫头鹰餐厅最大的特色是它的服务员。
全是20岁左右的姑娘，穿着非常非常非常紧身且非常非常短的。
短裤。
以及非常紧身的小衣服。
做服务员。
所以去hu特s吃饭的人全都是像我这样的。
中年怪叔叔。
就这么一句话，能交代多少东西啊？你说哪个爱女儿的父亲会让女儿去那个地方打工？
对，类似于女仆餐厅，你可以这么理解，但是穿的更更性感一些。
证明了几件事情。
第一，女儿是有点叛逆的。第二，家庭真的需要钱。
而且我跟你说，huters斯对女对女孩对女服务员的这个长相和身材要求也蛮高的，就确实。
女儿又很漂亮。
但是在那个地方打工。
认识。
O。
All right, that's right, is like that off your face a Yeah, blush I'm used to it.
看看丹泽尔华盛顿的演技。
我习惯了。
同一句台词说两次代表什么需要闪回吗？
简简单单一场戏，一个单亲爸爸带大两个女儿，两个女儿略微有些叛逆，不理他，但是他又很爱他们，他们马上要去读大学，有美好的前途，但是现在没有钱交学费，所有的东西都有了呀。
懂吗？
这就是我为什么不让你们去写闪回。
写点这种戏它不好吗？
为什么一定要去搞闪回呢？
来。
同学们，这节课我们谈到一个最重要的问题。
还是回到这个双篮组的问题。
这些都是小技巧啊，我们都要学以后都要用。
我们再回到这个双男柱的问题。
同学们。
假设这个剧本是你们写的。
或者是这个剧本现在摆到我们面前。
我们认为，不管再怎么剪辑，不管再怎么补救。
双男主中前部的戏还是太少，我们怎么办？
如果这个剧本到我们手里，我们认为主角不够明确，不够贯彻这个电影我们怎么办？
我给大家提两种修改方案。
第一个修改方案。
简单的方案啊。第一个。
把主角直接写成小美。
因为在整个故事的中前部，就是小美一次一次在补救。
然后雇他用了各种各样的人去补救这件事情。
那故事的。
那有些同学说，那最后他没解决问题呀，那我们得改呀。
开着车开着一辆皮卡冲过去的，我们就可以改成小美。
这种方法最简单啊，种的不多。
因为整个中前部折腾这俩人俩人也没什么事，跟他俩人没什么关系，确实镜头太多也太累了。虽然他是单子华盛顿，确实演技好，但是理论上我们本来是可以把主角改成小美的，只不过最后开着皮卡冲过去，接上小帅到第一节车厢的，可以换成小美。
这是最简单的一种改法。
把这两个人的戏份压缩，压的跟其他的工作人员差不多。
把主角直接给小美。
这是一种简单方法。
假设啊我们认为这个主角。
不明确这个故事不好，我们这是第一种简单的改法。
但是呢主这样的话，主角大部分时间在调度室其实也未必会好看。只不过。
只不过对吧？
会主角比较明确，比较符合教科书。
第一种改法。
我比较推荐第二种改法。
主角还是我们的刷男主。
但是。
他们俩开的。
对，刚才我为什么说那个我们先回到第一个啊，就是为什么我说小美可以在最后时刻开着那个大皮卡过去呢？同学们，你们有没有想过那个皮卡本身就是个bug？
那个皮卡没有必要载着脚受伤的小帅。
去爬上那个车呀，他在一个。
全国人去去去不就行了吗？
不一定要载着我们我们他妈受伤的小帅过去呢，小帅的脚伤成那样能蹦过去吗？
这是个bug呀，当然你可以解释是因为他们两个努力让车速下降，所以汽车才有追上的可能。
我们可以这么去理解，就是我们主角的。
努力让这个火车车速下降。
所以。
他们才有。
和火车并行跳过去的可能性。
我们可以去这么去理解啊。
但是我依然说那里有点bug了。
所以说这件事情完全可以小美自己去。
没有必要是那个人，既然都是bug了。
对吧来，我们回到第二种解法。
第二种解法，我们一起来研究一下，同学们啊静下心来，我们回忆一下这个故事的剧情，我们一起来解一下。
假设主角还是我们的老司机和小帅。
那么他们俩中前步的时候。
不是开着一辆。
1206。
他们开他们俩今天的任务。
是宰着小朋友。
参观帖。
主角开777那就完了，主角开777，那就整个变掉了。777就是脱轨的无人驾驶列车。
你们回到我的思路上来。
主角开的是。
小朋友们参观的火车，他们俩今天的任务是带着小朋友参观。
那么。
整个故事的中前部就是前面有一节脱轨的火车，我们载着小朋友。
但是躲不过去了怎么办？
所以在故事的终点之前，我们要救这群小朋友。
把小朋友救完之后，我们再去救777。
这样的话可以让整个故事的前部和后部都有事情可以做。
让这两个主角在故事的前部和后部都有事情去做。
而且。
为什么我们的小帅今天来。
开这个小朋友通过走后门，专门来跟我们的老司机搭档，开这个带着小朋友参观的车呀，为什么？
为什么你们告诉我为什么小帅为什么要上这类火车载这一帮小朋友参观车道啊，参观铁路啊。
他走后门来的呀。
因为他儿子在车上嘛，因为他老婆不允许他见儿子嘛。
所以整个故事的中前部，这两个人就有事儿干了，着急了。
脱轨的列车要撞向他们了。
然后其他都不变，整个的故事呢在终点以前，依然是这两个人要拯救这一车的孩子。等到把孩子们安全卸下，他们开着一个车头再去追死神号。
把这群孩子放下之后，他们开着这个车头再去追死讯号，而自己的儿子救下了，我要去救什么？
回忆一下AB故事，我故事的终点以前，我就自己的儿子。在故事的终点以后呢。
我去救千家万户的儿子。
这两个人不就都有事干了吗？
所以说啊。
那小朋友没用好。
哇，当然了，咱们是。
咱们是这个商业片编剧是吧？就喜欢搞得抓嘛一些。
拉马。
拉满听我的，拉满没有坏处，你们去看药神，看孤注一掷，都要拉满。
拉满啊让观众。
着急。
明白吧？
所以今天回去以后，所有的同学啊给我去尝试用这个方式去写一下这个1500字的故事。
在故事的终点以前。
他们俩开着这辆车在参观，带着小朋友参观，依然他们俩有两个人的矛盾，依然这个老头看出他以权谋私，两个人吵架，对吧？依然两个人有问题，依然会产生失误，导致他把这辆车至于危险。然后我们的老黑利用自己的经验是吧？力挽狂澜。
拯救了这辆车上的小朋友。
但是。
故事终点以后呢。
这些小朋友是安全了，还有更多的小朋友。
有同学说这么改，小帅没原罪没关系吗？你。
你自己改呀。
你自己去改呀，你自己去想办法呀。
自己去想办法好吗？我只是给你提供一个思路，你们自己去改改看，什么都可以动，什么都可以改。
我可以负责任的告诉你，这是一种非常好的解法。
回到我们这节课本身，我们这节课要学什么？
要学两个东西。
第一个东西就是事情发生在相对集中的时间的时候，我们写这样的故事要注意哪些？
故事发生在相对集中的时间段的时候。
也就是说，故事的长度有限的时候，我们要增加故事的宽度。
增加故事的宽度。
那我们就要做多人物，多视角。
这是我们今天要学的第一样东西。
故事发生在相对集中的时候，我们要增加事情的宽度。
主角的视角，家人的视角，工作人员的视角，参观人员的视角，上司的视角，老板的视角，新闻视角，然后路边百姓的视角，对吧？增加宽度。
然后在多人物的情况下，我们要要学会快速的交代人物性格。
同学们。
快速的交代人物性格，就需要选有视觉差异化的。
在这部电影里面，每一个角色的视觉差异极其大。
你看那些工作人员，简直他就是江南七怪啊。
铁路系统的工作人员简直然后用这些视角是吧？用这些视角来增加宽度啊，增加紧张度啊，增加这是啊我们学到的第一个问题。第二个问题就是。
真实事件改编怎么写？
真实事件改编呢由于他事情本身足够大。
所以它具有先天的吸引力。
但是他也有个问题，就是悬念不足。比如说你像迫降航班这种电影，我们都知道它安全降落了，我们为什么还要看，对不对？回头你们可以去看一下迫降航班啊，这种故事你们自己去看一下人家是怎么解答这个问题的。在这部电影里面，已知他们肯定可以拯救这个。
火车。
那我们给大家看什么呢？
给大家看。
七种解决方案。
但是其实我们不知道哪种方案能行，所以给了7种解决方案。
这两点自己先学到啊。
集中时间内的怎么写真实事件改编，有利有弊啊有利就是这件事情本身大家都喜欢。
对吧是个大事儿，上新闻的。
先天的吸力缺点就是什么呢？我们知道他们最后拯丢了吗，对吧？
然后刚才说到迫降航班啊，同学们拓展回去拓展你先自己记一下。除了迫降航班以外，还可以看一下生死时速。
提安娜raves的生死时速。
回去看一下。
另外再给我看一个类似于这样电影的真实事件改编的这样的电影，也是写的非常非常好的一个电影啊，非常非常好的一个电影叫理查德朱维尔的哀歌。
看过的课代表把这几些字打在评论区，理查德朱威尔的哀歌。
这部电影回去给我看。
真实事件改编。
非常的好看啊。喂。
勤快的同学。
回去给我至少写个梗盖，尝试的写一下，以这两个双男主为始终为解决问题的视角，增加他们的戏份，增加他们的紧张感，增加他们的主动力，然后让他们开着带小朋友参观的那辆车。
同学们去。
尝试一下。
同学说，如何训练chtGPT写故事有没有好的指指令啊？你用cht gPT写故事啊，我的建议还是一段一段写。
你自己去组合。呃，但是基本的指令还是这样啊，你首先得给他一个身份，你跟chatGPT沟通的时候啊，首先你要给他一个身份，就是呃比如说你是一个编剧啊，他是一个编剧，然后呢让他根据呃什么要求先写呃一个人物的出场。比如说然后呢在下一段呢再让他营造营造一个基本的对抗。
什么样的要求，然后给他多少字儿，所以基本的指令就是角色，然后要求呃角色内容要求这三部分啊，角色内容要求。但是我实操下来啊，呃你还是用它一段一段写，不要用它写整个，你咱们你们用chtGPT是有优势的。因为我给你们把故事拆解的已经非常细了。
对不对？我给你们把故事已经拆解的非常细了，这一段干啥这一段干啥这一段干啥，你们已经非常明确了。所以说你们不要去依赖猜的GPT，你们自己先写段落，然后让他给你补充段落内容是可以尝试的。好吧，基本的指令就是三部分，第一部分让他扮演什么角色，他现在是谁，然后呢写一个什么样的内容。
然后要求是什么？比如说要求是呃要感人，要求是要好笑，对吧？多少字以内就这三部分好不好？
不要让他直接帮你输出整段故事，你们都学编剧了，如果他能直接帮你输出整段故事，那你们和路人小白有什么区别？
对不对？你们肯定是让他精准的输出呀。
比如说你看我会跟他提什么要求啊，我现在要我的主角去问他妈要钱，请你帮我想三个方法。
我现在要写一个故事，我们这个角色是一个8岁的小朋友，现在他要问他妈要钱啊，你帮我写这么一段戏，希望他有三种常三种以上的方法方法去尝试。你你是这么具体的指令，那车的GPT绝对可以帮到你呀，是不是？
还是那句话，你不能说给我写一个牛逼的故事。那如果这样能写出来的话，那你也不用学编剧了。
好吧。
那就这样吧，同学们，咱们下周见。
。